[Music]
i don't think there is a contradiction
between a simple life
and a spicy food
perhaps
someone who's living a simple life
needs to have something to spice it up
maybe that works
[Music]
my name is father richard walls and i am
a monk of subiaco abbey which is a
monastery in subiaco arkansas
after i graduated from high school i
entered the monastery
so i've been
55 years a month
[Applause]
monk sauce which we produce here at
subiaco abbey
is an habanero pepper sauce we call that
monk sauce because it's monk made
anybody who has handled habanero peppers
knows that you should not be doing this
without a
glove on
a good monk is a
good balance between prayer and work
[Music]
it ought to be done
find out if it's any good
where's the water
[Music]
i suspect that a lot of people have kind
of fanciful ideas about monks and what
they do and
they get into the monastery and they
find out that monks are very much like
everybody else
[Music]
i
feel very close connection to the land
in this area
the longer that i was here the more i
realized that god
got me here because he knew how to be in
a community
the community is a very important thing
to me
[Music]
we are the only neneri in all the
himalayas doing deadly martial art
these nuns can even break bricks with
their hands
and the purpose behind this practice is
sacred this is a lifelong purpose i make
it for tupa order and i am very proud of
my practice
my name is jigme yangchin kamo jigme
means fearless
i'm a confunant
of the drupal order
the drukpa order is a branch of buddhism
that has been around for thousands of
years
but in 2008 the nunnery based in
kathmandu nepal started to learn kung fu
as part of their spiritual practice
800 nuns are here in drupal now jigmei
wanted to be a nun since she was a
little girl
i'm 10 years old when i became a nun
i constitute all the nuns like my family
[Music]
no other nunnery in nepal does kung fu
training
and jigme and her sisters go the extra
mile to master this art form the drupal
order is not for lazy people we wake up
at 3am we meditate we bicycle we train
for the three hours they run and climb
up stairs to strengthen their bodies and
they use sticks and fans to enhance
their coordination the hard work is
rewarding
and the purpose of training these nuns
to fight all comes back to the
philosophies of peace and equality
comfort train us to focus our mind for
meditation
the nuns also take these philosophies
and apply them to disadvantaged
communities in nepal
in 2015 when a devastating earthquake
hit kathmandu the nuns knew this was
their call to action
when the earthquake healed our comfort
training helped us to brave and strong
we went to many villages that many and
jews and government thought that it's
too dangerous we brought many supplies
we survived the landslide avalanches and
earthquake
the nuns also biked 14 000 miles
throughout nepal to protest against the
human trafficking of women and girls we
talk about equality and safety
we wanted to show everyone that nuns can
ride bicycle and girls can do anything
i learned i can do anything a man can't
kungfu has trained me to be confident
strong and happy
the teachings helped me put my
compassion into action
helping others is my religion
[Music]
the shaolin monks of china are an
ancient order surrounded in mystery
they spend their lives learning kung fu
and buddhist philosophy
you can choose to practice martial arts
or choose to pray
[Music]
but i choose
combined both together i chose the worst
way
after defecting from communist china one
shaolin monk found himself living in new
york training some unique clients
ranging from movie stars to hip-hop
artists
my name is sriamin
i'm the founder and arbit of usa shaolin
temple
[Music]
i was training at the park
first some training
said do you want to teach we want to
study
and i said no problem
and people talk to people you know
spreading the words out very quickly
i have students come from everywhere
from around the world they come here
just for one week sometimes a month
they just come here to study
as xi'an ming's popularity grew his
teachings began attracting the attention
of one of new york's most famous hip-hop
artists
the shifu has spent years training with
rizza from wu-tang clan even going so
far as to appear in the music video for
shaolin temple
[Applause]
a perfect faith
clan
they love chinese culture
they love martial arts
[Music]
but xi'an ming strongly believes that
the benefits of shaolin can be adapted
for any individual
anybody can get it benefited because
different kind of styles
for different people
never old never young never told
i never assured
plan for everybody
i want to reach as many people as
possible
in my precious lifetime
that's my ultimate goal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
character mistakes
[Music]
[Music]
on a greek peninsula sits mount ethos
one of the most important centers of the
christian orthodox world
isolated and autonomous monks first
arrived in the 9th century and it is a
place where time has stood still
access is very limited and the location
is hard to get to especially on the
southern side
where cabins sit on cliffs a hundred
feet above the sea
[Music]
suggested
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
my
amongst life on mount ethos is almost
exclusively dedicated to prayer
beyond that life is rooted in
self-sustainability
monks grow their own fruits and
vegetables make their own wine and do
any required handiwork
[Music]
it
[Music]
here
[Music]
mount ethos remains a holy site where
numbers of visitors and prospective
monks continues to rise every year
to some outsiders this simple communal
life may seem archaic but for the monks
it is a peaceful existence with no
distractions
[Music]
is